5 25 on your wednesday morning so the 10
mile long labor day holiday backups may
be gone but there's still a double
whammy for you on the i-15 around prim
we start with the nevada department of
transportation spokesman justin hopkins
says both the off and on ramps on the
south 15 to and from prim are shutting
down tonight tomorrow night the good
news is they won't be closed at the same
time from nine tonight tomorrow night
until five tomorrow and friday morning
they're alternating ramp repaving part
of the overall plan to improve the drive
into southern california and indot
points out that while drivers heading
through may not have access to prim the
contractors making sure employees can
get in and out of the area now to the
california side where in addition to the
diversion for all drivers at the
agriculture check station caltrans is
doing alternating lane closures for
repaving and concrete barrier
installation this work is scheduled to
start at six each evening and run until
10 the next morning the rest of the week
oh boy so caltrans says all of their
work will be done by friday morning so
nothing should get in the way for your
friday night drive down to cali you want
to go all over this again just check out
the online version of this story on
eight newsnow dot com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com